keep the camera rolling jeff say but you
guys say
and i say i i have 10 other things let
me hear watch this the guy
and i just started improving really fun
[Music]
jurassic park
here's a little bit about that golly
i've had a big history and a little bit
of a future coming up with it um
because we did a jurassic world dominion
that's called jurassic world colon i
think is with the title dominion and
colin trevorrow wrote it directed he's
wonderful and we were always the
beginning of covent so we were all
bubbled up in a hotel near pinewood
studios and this is the original cast
with laura dern and
sam neal and uh when and me kind of uh
put together with bryce dallas howard
and and uh chris pratt but also with uh
dewanda wise and bd
wong and omar
smith big uh delightful cast and i think
it's going to be good so it'll be out
this summer but it takes us back and
allowed me to play step into the shoes
again of dr eden malcolm raise your hand
don't move i'm going to do the same
thing start with the same same place
again which way he's going to roll off
doesn't it
let's say back same way
it changed
it changed why
because tiny variations
uh the the orientation of the hairs on
your hands look at this um the amount of
blood distending your vessels
imperfections in the skin it was
originally beautifully rendered in
michael creighton's book which i read
around the time that somebody said hey
steven spielberg wants to would like to
meet you on this movie who says i read
the book read the script uh went in at
that first meeting he said hey you know
i wanted to meet you i you know have
enjoyed what you've done there's a
current uh consensus and a faction at
least in my group here that thinks that
the script should uh develop a little
and uh we may take your character out of
it and uh put that character that was in
the book
malcolm
and kind of
meld it into the grand character so you
know it's kind of one one guy and
i was uh well
really
and i made a little pitch you know in my
way for well off the top of my head
i think you might might enjoy having
that character there
because or i you know
i'd be remiss before i left if i didn't
say that i think you want somebody to i
whatever i said you know
not that that swayed him in any way but
luckily it wound up in the in the movie
and uh so then we go to hawaii which we
which was the first two weeks of both
those shoots the first and the second
the lost world and we go to hawaii and
uh i sort of
contributed i
searched around for my costume
and my glasses so we went to the costume
person and said
how about this and they i think they
took most of that so it's most of what i
uh brought i think and they took some
pictures and students miller would know
he doesn't rehearse at least in that he
didn't rehearse he won in fact on the
set he didn't want to rehearse until he
turned the switch on he said because you
know if you do it then i you know have
we photographed it into that i think
when we should it should cook to full it
should come to full boil when we we're
we're filming it and uh i do love that i
love many other approaches and different
kinds of things but i loved how he does
that what a creative force and a sweet
available delightful
you know once in a lifetime once in a
generation uh landmark cinema man he is
uh full of stories and enjoyment and and
creative juice he's uh has a child like
enthusiasm and when he's there so
prepared but he goes i know what we can
do let's do you know so he's you're
following him doing that and he's the
whole thing is moving very beautifully
unauthorized breeding in jurassic park
how do you know they can't breathe
well because all the animals in jurassic
park are female
oh
we've engineered them that way even
though it's a big movie a big production
and their dinosaurs and
all of that it feels like a kind of an
independent workshop where he's very
sensitive to and interested in the
characters and
you know
ways of maybe improvising certain things
so um that was delightful ooh how about
in in hurricane aniki in that first in
jurassic park in 93 we went to kauai in
hawaii and hurricane iniki as has been
talked about many times struck the
island
shortly before we finished and we were
stuck there all of us in the baller the
crew and the cast and stephen in the
ballroom of that
thing my character says you know we not
only we humans not only lack dominion
over nature we're subordinate to it
the wise
idea is that we have to
live
a peacefully with other creatures here
figure out how to do it so they have as
much safety and liberty as we do and
align ourselves with nature so that it
works out for all of us and the
environment and the planet et cetera et
cetera life uh uh finds a way yeah uh i
don't know that they'd written in the ah
maybe i contributed that uh uh but uh i
don't wanna take a cr pat myself break
my arm pat myself on the back it's not
possible listen if there's one thing the
history of evolution has taught us that
life will not be contained life breaks
free it expands to new territories and
it crashes through barriers painfully
maybe even dangerously but uh
well there it is
there it is
you're implying that a group composed
entirely of female animals will
breed no i'm i'm simply saying that life
uh finds a way we didn't know uh that
that would be like that and life
uh finds a way so that kind of
yeah that's kind of
kept around people have enjoyed that and
isn't that something
independence day
that uh
was a popular movie at the time you know
um
roland emerick it's a wonderful fella i
enjoy him so much and he was uh young
and full of beans and so were we all and
uh
aliens and dean devlin uh it was very
fun to work with and we improvised uh
here and there and me and will smith and
the cockpit of that thing and
and that was fun and
walking at the end on those salt flats
we've stayed in some hotel at the border
of
nevada and
utah or something like that in some
hotel where the casinos were in the you
know
and then we drove out to these salt
flats that what you see in the movie
that's not cgi it's a long area of
otherworldly looking terrain saved the
world defeated the thing and uh the
camera was way far away and me and will
smith were smoking these cigars
uh they make me dizzy i'm not a smoker
of cigarettes or cigars and by the time
you know
you go
and get it lighted
i'm already groggy
and woozy
so finally these weren't the days of uh
where passing germs
was such an issue so i asked the ad the
very generous ad hey can you get this
going for me so when they say action you
can hand it to me lighted and then i can
on this on screen take a few
and that's about all i can do because
we're doing this over and over again my
dad oh boy judd hirsch well you see a
man can leave us in thailand
i don't want you to catch cold
what is that what's the matter with you
geez
and harvey fierstein was great they
marketed that thing with a in the super
bowl i remember watching the super bowl
in some party and wow they said they
were going to do that but wow that's a
that's commercial and they destroy the
white house that was kind of provocative
and and uh interesting and it kind of
caught on and gee that was fun and the
aliens we're gonna have to make a run
for this one here let's get low let's
get fast i got you big daddy let's get
him
watch the deck
[Music]
well i'll tell you the issue of aliens
for one reason or another i can't
uh uh tell you why i can't disclose
secret that i'm holding but i just
recently um you know i've done other
things with aliens i was an alien and
earth girls are easy
and i became overtaken by aliens
invasion of the body snatchers and in
buckaroo banzai across the eighth
dimension uh i battled aliens and so you
know i've had my brushes and elbow rubs
with um aliens of one kind another and i
may have
i can't say anymore i can't say anymore
about something but there's a secret
that i'm holding which has caused me to
do a little serious
just because i'm interested in it
uh in
the possibility of in of life
uh
somewhere else in the universe
the question of uh intelligent life
somewhere there as we
have construed intelligence so-called
and what our place might be in that
family if there's anybody else out there
and the fermi paradox do you know about
that and
where is everybody and uh
i'm currently very
interested in it
flying
david cronenberg
sends this script and i think you know i
grew up in pittsburgh and my sister and
i used to go to the leona theater in
homestead and see beautiful gold theater
and see
uh many for the first run of oh my god a
bridge on the river kwai and great
movies and a lot of roger corman movies
and the sadist and ega
and uh a lot of vincent price movies
including probably the fly
so when i got this script
i think i had a
kind of thrill thrilling association
already with it and then it's such a
wonderful script dave cronenberg so
smart what an artist and so individual
and it was wonderful and what a part
very
chewy and uh delicious i kind of
was very excited right away we talked
about it and
and there we there we go
i was not pure the teleporter insisted
interface not pure
i don't know what you mean
a fly
got into the
transmitter pied with me that first time
when i was alone chris whales who won
the oscar for the
makeup that he did uh um designed this
thing and i remember going to his shop
you know with david cronenberg early on
and they had he had drawn out the
different stages of my devolution and we
talked about it and then i started to
try on some things and they photographed
them and you know it was a very
thoughtful and um careful process and
masterful and artful process stefan
dupuis was the was his cohort chris
wallace's who got me in finally the
dentist's chair it's starting at three
in the mornings i remember in toronto
and uh did five hours of makeup on me to
put this stuff on and uh during which i
meditated on the part and i got ready
for the day and uh then you know
technology being what it was makeup
technology it starts to fall apart right
away so the whole rest of the day he's
taking it up and gluing it down again
gluing it down again at the end of the
day not that i'm complaining they didn't
have a solvent to take it all off but
you know it's an hour of rub rub rub rub
rub rub rub rub rub your skin as red now
and you know all that kind of stuff but
it was fine they took great care of me
and of course doing that project he and
i i had an idea
there is an idea about the ending that i
had became passionate about i didn't
want john getz's
character to win finally and for me to
become a kind of a
i don't know what i was protecting at
that point but i had a big passionate
idea about it i said no don't let them
be together at the end let them
she's developed something about her
being devoted to me or i i don't know
what we can hashed out some kind of
collaboration
i enjoyed it very much i think he did
too as i became the fly i don't think i
had i hadn't really practiced and kind
of
developed a real
concrete idea about how he would behave
physically in this net i as the story
goes i did find a fly and looked at a
fly put in a plastic bag and looked at
it and how it was moving around so got
something from that i think on the day
when i put on the thing finally
things kind of came had to come together
and they did i remember the first thing
we shot is when i when i am fully flied
out i crashed through that glass brick
wall
in the medical facility and you know
you know do something like that you know
i had to come up with it but we did it
it was just a joy to do and then his
wonderful words in sec politics and this
and that really really fun and the tra
the tragedy of it uh the romantic
tragedy of it really
uh delicious to chew on and uh of course
mel brooks
produced it brooks films you know i
loved him and then you know it was all
done and i went to uh times square
i think for the opening and boy it was a
raucous crack because nobody knows how
it's going to play or anything it was a
i stood in the back and it was a real
raucous
crowd that seemed to enjoy it
that night uh it was a thrilling and in
the decades to come it see it gets
enjoyed and people come up to me and
say one thing or another
and uh i'm thrilled that i did it was a
high point creatively
and uh
and uh career-wise too
thor ragnarok gee i had a good time on
that
i took uh emily goldblum and the kids
charlie river to
knobby beach on the gold coast of
australia and the great
man and the great director taika waititi
was there we had met before he's he'd
said hey you want to talk about this
maybe you should do this part in this
thing and we met at a hotel in los
angeles near my house and uh i had seen
for the meeting the other thor movies
and i had some ideas and i'd read that
script and he and we talked he's so
smart and good and heartfelt and
authentic and unusual and hilarious and
full of the energy of life uh so fun
from the start so i i jumped on board
and he said you know i don't want you to
do anything theatrical or cartoony i
think who you are kind of and you're
part of your straight behavior
is a little bit useful in this so-called
character i think we'll dress you up in
some way but uh i think you can be
contemporary and uh and kind of a little
bit in this vein that we're talking
about and and i like to improvise a lot
and i said well me too
and then we got to the set and i'll be
dying if it wasn't as much fun as i've
ever had whenever we get to talking
topaz about scrapper142 what do i always
say she is the and it starts with a b
trash
no not trash
were you waiting to just call her that
it doesn't start with a b
booze hank
uh uh uh i'm so sorry no best i was i
was thinking about best because i always
say you're the best she brought me my
beloved champion you know he says that
every time she's here what have you
brought today tell me he would say yeah
yeah let's do this because it's a big uh
you know big machine that has to work
and a big story that has to be told but
he said now that we're here
i got 10 other ideas about things you
could say keep the camera rolling jeff
say but gaga guys say
and i say i have 10 other things let me
hear watch this the guy you got
and i just started improving really fun
time works real different around these
parts on any other world i'd be like uh
millions of years old but here on cigar
in any case you know this uh this uh you
call yourself lord of thunder god of
thunder
i've never met this man in my life he's
my brother adopt it is he any kind of a
fighter
you take this thing out of my neck and
i'll show you oh look at that he's
threatening me hey sparkles here's the
deal you want to get back to ass's place
asperger that's god any contender who
defeats
my champion their freedom they shall win
fine then point me in the direction of
whoever's asked how you have to kick
that's what i call
contender we're a good team
uh at least in my humble opinion and uh
i i enjoy him very much and that whole
operation at marvel kevin feige and
lewis esposito and victoria alonso they
know what they're doing and they build
in reshoots a schedule that involves
reshoots and they have taika trust that
he's going to make something interesting
and different out of it and they want to
make popular movies but
high quality movies and i i love them
and i love what they do
and
i have a secret another secret that i'm
holding that i cannot disclose
that
well i i must say i just have a a a
current and uh
and living
affection for taika and uh i love that
that uh character and i can't say any
more look i'm already expectorating over
the
the ideas i can't say any more than that
the world court of jeff goldblum is a
series for those who don't know it's a
series that newtopia a productive
wonderful production company uh did for
nat geo and it's being released on
disney plus we did a season of it of a
dozen episodes that came out a little
bit ago you can still stream it on your
disney plus and see many episodes and
ice cream sneakers
jewelry cosmetics pools rvs gaming
different things then we did another
season during the pandemic
mostly where uh we were going to not go
all over the country
but uh kind of limited to la but then
somehow during the thing la became iffy
and we went to atlanta and we shot there
for a month five
of the new ten episodes of season two
are being released on
disney plus day which is november 12th
the episodes
are
dogs
dance
magic
monsters
and
fireworks
what
is that i i i don't understand the
syntax here no smoking open flames wait
a minute wait a minute see this comma
here no smoking open
flames i think i mean open flames oh hey
good so
[Laughter]
so forget that all unauthorized persons
and vehicles
[Music]
you know
beware i guess turned back turn back
turn back
we're authorized i i really like them i
i recommend them and they'll be out you
can stream them and then five more will
be sent your way if you like uh sometime
a little after the first of the year and
i can't tell you what those episodes are
but it's it's it's a series that allows
me
to invite you and take you and guide you
on a little half hour journey of
exploration and adventure and science
uh secrets and uh mysteries and
knowledge uh
that i discover on one particular
subject or thing that we all seem to
love and seems to be familiar but there
might be some extraordinary things about
this ordinary uh familiar thing like the
character in in our town who goes i wish
i'd
i wish i'd appreciated
when i was there
all the dogs that i saw or the ability
to dance
so it's a little bit that there's
wonderment and
phantasmagorical transmogrification
available and plenty of uh
me
doing it's messing with the form you
know i didn't want to do something
conventionally documentary like you've
seen a host do i didn't want to kind of
make it easy for myself and read a
teleprompter but i i do what i'm doing
now and kind of
like
expel my thoughts such as they are and
feelings
to my friends in camera land emily and
we're about to as the sun beautifully
goes down on this epic
landscape
off
some fireworks
and then i encounter people that they
would cast
brilliantly and recruit and research
these things and then take left turns
and sequences uh in an episode on
fireworks we talk to an astronaut
about the stars because fireworks really
mimic in some ways uh the star is the
show that the stars put on every night
and allow ourselves to look up to see
and then we
we we explore
our place in the universe and the shape
and size and dimensions in the universe
a little bit um so things like that in
dance i wind up doing a dance with a sea
lion
uh believe it or not in dogs i get taken
around and on a mushing urban mushing
thing and some rickety thing over a
bouncy landscape with a team of uh
huskies you know uh
there's some uh weird wonderful stuff
and for monsters i go up to the
mysterious and dark uh forests of the
north of the northwest and with people
who are looking for bigfoot
so anyway that's a little bit about the
series uh i i love it and then i gave
him my whole photo albums from when i
was a kid uh
and my home movies when i was in
pittsburgh that include my parents and
my family and then my wife emily
goldblum and the kids include themselves
in a couple of things
so when i watch them i'm delighted by
these episodes amused by myself and
everybody else and i'm choked up i get
choked up on camera a couple of times
and when i see them
i'm
i'm i adore them so anyway that's me
thank you uh says jeff goldman so much
for your time and and uh bearing up with
this and watching uh watching me talk
about this and if i happened
on the off chance that i missed anything
that you wanted me to talk about or any
parts that you were thinking about uh
maybe i'll see you in the future i'll
i'll arrange such a thing and and we can
talk about things in the future all
there's always there's plenty more where
that came from